but making women cover up for things
that gold na gave them is inherently
sexualizing okay then why don't we walk
around naked that's just that's just
decency and modesty with the
restrictions that is places on it like
covering your where but where does
morality come from cuz what you've said
is now for example who decides okay
argument why can't a woman not show her
nipples a man can go
topless Islam net is racing funds to
establish a mid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sakar
for you because every person that comes
a step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate what you can
so what's your name fiso Fel and sister
fisa f oh Fel and fisa
okay no sorry is Sarah sorry Sarah okay
okay Sarah okay so let's start off with
okay let's do a question each what uh
you said you was a Muslim yeah okay what
used to be musl yeah sure what what caus
you to I I I I was not Muslim 11 years
ago I came to Islam 11 years ago
okay yeah yeah so I believed I always
believed in God but I had no religion
yeah I mean wait what was your question
story so basically what what caused you
uh to leave Islam just that I just
didn't really ever really believe in it
when I was ever practicing it ever
whenever I go to Moscow prayer and stuff
I just didn't really like believe in it
in the sense of like I didn't really
actually believe there was an Al up in
the like up there like a god in general
and when I became older I just started
to question it more and question some of
the practices I guess and like see how
other people are treat to another Middle
Eastern countries like in the Middle
East you know how it's illegal to be gay
like adultery being punished by stoning
and so I just didn't really agree with
that and I thought that was very
implicated in the way they implemented
Syria law and overall the concept of
Islam just something that I do really
agree with I do really practice so I
just thought why would I why would I
believe in something I don't practice I
actually believe in in my heart so it's
interesting because the thing is I was
in a similar place in the sense where I
always believed in a higher power but
it's like agnostic I was I believed in
God so I was a theist I was a theist
yeah so I was a theist but to me I was
like what's the purpose of life like
this very place I used to come clubbing
here every week myself partying all that
kind of stuff but I came to a point
where I was like there's more to life I
can't just be living my life like this I
mean my socks have more of a purpose can
can you imagine my socks have a purpose
I don't have a purpose I was like this
is this not good okay how it's not
really nice thing to say by yourself no
but it's a very important thing to say
humans like we don't need to have a
purpose to just here to help people and
be nice like why you have purpose but
that is a purpose so what you what you
said there about helping people is a
purpose correct okay but nothing to do
with religion you don't need religion to
be good it have more to do with nature
and empathy we can come to that but the
point is this myself when I look at
myself I believe I'm designed i' I'm
complex in design yeah when I look at my
socks my socks are also designed maybe
not as complex as myself but I was
asking myself how could my mere socks
have a design have a purpose have a
designer but me as a human being who's
far more complex in design who can think
for himself make decisions has a will
just I'm just here randomly and I don't
know what I'm doing now I was I can't
accept that so that's when I started
looking for my purpose now your question
I think would you say you came from more
of a cultural background where Islam was
just told to you to just pray without
explanation I would definitely say that
I would definitely also say that like
living in London as well I probably also
influenced me more than would if I lived
in like Saudi Arabia I'd probably be
more of a Muslim then I'd probably come
to different conclusions in Saudi Arabia
not necessarily well probably cuz if you
live in London can I just if you live in
London you're you're exposed to more
people you're exposed to more belief
there's not really like an incentive to
practice compared to Saudi Arabia where
they Implement Islamic State and the
national religion there is Islam
compared to it was more Christianity is
more secular so there would be inment in
when you come to believe in Islam that
would impact that don't you think okay
let me tell you something let me know if
I'm wrong this argument which it is
partially true that your environment can
have an impact on your decision-making
factors which I'm going to come to later
I was born in the UK my family hates
Islam hates Islam like deep deep hatred
because of some issues back in the days
I became a muslim with all of those
factors around meing partying all that
kind of stuff I mean I'm not saying that
can't be true no no no so my argument is
follow there are people in Mecca you
know Mecca where we do go that
pilgrimage that have not gone and
performed pilgrimage once you live in
the city bro the ca is 10 minutes away
from you but they have not they haven't
gone to Haj let alone they don't even
pray so to me partially true and
partially not in the sense your external
factors can have an influence to yes But
ultimately if you are someone who is
seeking the truth if they put you in an
Island full of atheists you will believe
in God so partially I agree and
partially not it's one's determination
in finding the truth but then if you're
put in a Land of Muslims you also you
might not end up believing in God anyway
so isn't that good so that's my point
when I mention Saudi Arabia majority
Muslim there are atheists there that's
the case here well in London Muslim you
know there's a like believing in God and
believing in religion we believe in
Creator believing in religion is a whole
different thing but I believe my sarah
sarah sarah yeah Sarah I believe you do
follow
religion no I believe in God no no no I
believe you follow a religion as would
you say you're atheist no I no I believe
that go atheist that you don't so you
believe in you're a theist I believe in
God but I don't believe in religion I
believe agnostic istic is when you made
agnostic is more like there's a power
there I don't know what it is is more of
a personal God
yes are you a I would say I'm an atheist
yeah okay you're an atheist so I believe
that both for you follow a religion how
let me make my argument yeah if I asked
you how do you believe this universe
came to me Evolution natural selection
Bing b SCI Mother Nature brilliant so
that to you what you've done is the
difference between me and you is the
following I believe there is a creator
that has the will that brought this into
existence you believe it's natural
selection random chance and evolution
that BR it so what you called God is
Mother Nature I call God of who he is so
you're giving the credit to Mother
Nature I'm giving the credit to God now
when it comes to how you live your life
let me ask you a question do you drink
alcohol uh not really no occasionally no
okay that's good do you eat pork no okay
so what is your dietry like can you eat
any kind of food um I usually I don't
really like think about it I just like
take I tried to I tried to eat healthier
recently say something like I think
you're trying to like get the answer
like that he might drink alcohol but
alcohol I know there are some benefits
to alcohol like just like there's some B
like you're eating junk food junk food
also is really bad for you but like in
moderation it's actually bad like I
think even atheist they would agree that
too much alcohol is bad for you no one's
like arguing that it's but like to
completely cut it off it's like it's and
music is also Haram as well which is
literally like helps people get out of
depression like help like rape and stuff
like that so I don't understand why
something is so beautiful that brings
the whole Community Music is one thing
that brings people together and food so
like why would that something so I'm
going into some different top toing I
think you made a value point I asked
that was when I cuz my argument was to
prove that you follow a religion which
was that not that when you look at
alcohol there's new studies that show
any kind of alcohol is harmful for you
not only that play a direct result in
breast cancer alcohol even too much
alcohol any I like alcohol increase that
recent studies you can check in science
journalist journalism you can check it
that any kind of alcohol has been
established now as not even you know
like oh I just have every all kind of
alcohol has been determined as harmful
to you you know why because nobody
starts with just I'm just gonna have one
it always leads to that but that's not
my argument my argument is the following
to your lifestyle you can if you want
you can drink alcohol I am told alcohol
is not permissible if you want you can
eat any kind of meat I'm told not to eat
pork the difference is not in many it's
not that different which is why I'm
mentioning this you follow a way of life
I follow a way of life well that follows
a way of life I don't really follow a
way life I just people difference
religion Islam is like very Islam is
like a set of foundation of Muslims
Muslims are very can be very they can be
judgmental
Jud religion itself and I feel the
difference between a religion and
someone who doesn't believe in a
religion is that there's no restrictions
on you when you live a when you are an
atheist there's only any restrictions on
what you can do so you're nobody living
a s way of life you're not don't
restrict you're just living life not
living a certain set of Standards that's
my point so you not having standards is
your way of life us having standards
that we cannot do is my way of life we
both have a way of life that has
different terms and conditions that's my
argument when somebody comes and says
you are a Muslim you follow religion I
say hold on a second as an atheist you
also follow religion that's not the same
thing as a religion anyway the FOC point
of Rel way of life though that's not the
same thing as religion that's like
saying if you if you're a vegetarian
that's a way of life but they don't
believe in that doesn't mean they
believe in like a plant God does it no
no no it's not but the thing is they are
following a way of life my argument is
the following we have the creation
telling us what to do and then we have
the Creator telling us what to do my
argument is that when people come to
this impression and think that as
Muslims we follow a God and they don't
I'm like okay cuz Allah tell us in the
Quran have you seen the one that has one
master compared to the one who has
multiple Masters what does that mean
that means for example would you agree
that your societal societal pressures
peer pressure the things that you watch
have a impact on your decision-making
factors yeah that's the case for
everyone good so that means you are not
actually necessarily free when you come
and say I'm an atheist I choose to do a
I say not really because when I was not
a believer in any religion let me tell
you something the way I dressed was
impacted by my Society it wasn't cuz I
wanted to it was because I believed I
look good in something which like I
always give this example I had a
specific jumper that I believed I looked
really good in I used to go to the clubs
here there was used to be a Penthouse
Club up there yeah I used to wear this
jumper that was so uncomfortable but I
used to wear it cuz I believed I look
good in it I would go and do extra hours
in work why so I can fund a specific
life lifestyle why because of opposite
gender Etc so was I actually free no I
wasn't external factors were playing a
role in the way I dress the way my hair
looks the way I go gym and all of these
factors so when we come and say oh I'm
free not necessarily the difference is
the following one follows the creation
one follows the Creator now when I
follow the Creator Islam which will come
to let's get argument to go there if God
exists because you're an atheist is that
Allah tells me this is what you can do
this is what you can't do I'm like
that's good cuz before I used to follow
multiple people
girls peer pressure trying to be rich
trying to be that now real girls are
real that's something we can see them
God like if you being genuinely honest
there's not a million per that you know
what you're right there's not a million
per there's a billion what we can see is
is what what's there no okay s Let me
Give an example Let me Give an example
sorry forgive me Let me Give an example
just to touch on this are you telling me
that you only believe in things you see
I'm not saying that okay so I'll ask you
a question do you something like God
you'd have to like really have some M
cuz you know there's so much rules in
Islam there something that's so like
restrictive I need something absolutely
like tangible for me to see to believe
in it for a man you could dress like
that but I can't just like I can't wear
trousers I can't there's lots I have to
cover I have to cover from my to my
KN serious the
UK still but I not serious I wear a job
I have to is it a women's like body I'm
sorry why do why didn't the God why
doesn't the like Quran focus on the fact
that men need to like um control the
themselves not just oh lower your gaze
that's nothing maybe put the emphasis on
them maybe like
Islam is the only religion no I believe
the Western was sexualizes woman the
West woman is the one every time but
making women cover up for things that
gold na gave them is inherently
sexualizing okay then why don't we walk
around
naked because we cover up that's just
that's just decency and modesty kids
deccy modesty okay why is that wrong
they were born naked do you get it so
where but even then with the
restrictions that is places on it like
covering your where do but where does
morality come from cuz what you've said
is now for example who decides okay
argument why can't a woman not show her
nipples a man can go topless I mean
there's different reasons but I mean of
course because men can do whatever they
want like okay but why w women sexualize
men who have shist so why how's that I
don't understand and also lesbians can
see G but there was also they're also
sexualizing them so I don't times Chang
over time it used to be 100 years ago it
used to be that woman can wear trousers
for example but West in society they can
so environment and the times change over
time so that can also factor into why
they it can't it doesn't have to be
religion it can mainly just okay good
but my argument is the following let's
first just deal with it one by one you
said about seeing bu are you telling me
that for example what you see touch feel
taste hear is the only things you
believe in because I'll ask you a
question can you see your Consciousness
no but do you believe you're conscious
yes well that's something that's like
like is it proven it's proven by
scientific studies of the brain and yeah
it is prove to me any science the
scientist have a big question as soon as
you get hit in the head by a bullet you
die no but still there's a big
connection is it connected to the brain
there's a whole discussion called is B
the whole book's written on called the
hard problem of Consciousness is it
connected to the brain or not always
sorry let me just make this argument is
the following for example you do know
that our CS renew itself all of our
cells in our body yeah okay then why
don't we become somebody else when the
cells in our brain renew that's not how
cells work cells but they renew yeah so
then why don't I why don't I become
somebody else cuz that's not how cells
would work they don't just make you
become a whole entire person you're the
same person you're just sheding cells
over time and that's just a normal human
process but it's not going to make you
it's not going to make you like become a
whole person whole but if my conscious
is connected to my brain and my brain
are made out of cells and if cells renew
itself my argument is that Consciousness
there's a whole discussion on it that
it's connected to the brain my point is
this there are things we believe in that
we don't see Dark Matter dark matter is
something that we cannot see touch feel
taste or hear but we see the effects of
it scientists study dark matter and they
come to conclusions about it so we get
our information from them that's the
same thing sorry what's the conclusion
they came to that we cannot observe it
we can't observe it but we see the
effects of it we see the effects but we
can't we don't know we we don't know
that God exists we can see the effects
of dark matter but we don't know that
God exists himself to see the dark see
his effects on our world we do because
you we are the effect so when I say we
can't see we can't just say that without
any proof but I am I'm using science as
an example that they cannot observe dark
matter they cannot see dark matter they
cannot touch dark matter they cannot
smell dark matter they cannot hear dark
matter they cannot feel dark matter but
they believe Dark Matter exists answer
question can we see I don't really think
that's how it works I'm going be honest
no but that's not that's that's a fact
we canot see that's not really how
science works as science is supposed to
be observable no but that's my point
that's what I'm seeing in science
literature there deduction as well yes
so the point is that they come to the
fact that they see the effects of Dark
Matter even though they don't observe it
with their five sense because like you
said science is all about observing even
though they don't they see the remnants
of it it's the same with God you don't
see touch you're placing the effects of
the world on God when you don't know if
it's God doing that first place no but I
have evidence for that that the first
thing I mention you TR to say our world
is the evidence though because that's
just of course I can because that that's
like okay so I could say I could say the
Christian God is the same thing he's
he's the reason for this helping us mtip
differents really strong evidence that
God is firstly it is all loving really
should be firstly we have to agree that
just because you don't see something
doesn't mean it doesn't exist because I
gave the example of Consciousness and
dark matter two things that we don't see
what we believe exists yeah but there's
no evidence that God exists there's n
but we but for to be consistent we
accept conscious and dark matter exist
without us observing stud's done on both
the stud done on both to observe the
results to them and then to see like
what they can there is not a single
study that is done on Dark Matter or
Consciousness that to say that we can
see it zero yeah but you can look inside
the brain to see how the brain works you
can you can put wires in the brain and
see we can see our brain and we can see
the we can see how different parts of
the brain interact with each other and
how they our Consciousness you can't do
that with God you can't stud God when
you put when they see put things in your
head and they see how your brain Act
works I am talking about Consciousness
it is immaterial consciousness is
immaterial dark matter is immaterial
what I'm saying is we see the effects of
it now I'm saying can we see God no can
we touch God no can we feel God no can
we taste God no but we still if we're
consistent if you accept dark matter and
Consciousness without seeing touching
feeling tasting or he why is there a
double standard when it comes to God
that's how it works Dark Matter
conscious things and especially when
dark man Consciousness are different
processes that there are studies done in
them and no are like ways to physically
see them if you think of the
Consciousness in the brain there is no
okay well we disag no not disagree there
is there is not a single study I'm just
genuinely not just win an argument
genuinely there is not a single study
that says there is not a single study
that says we can observe that studies on
the brain on how that works how that
different how how people went a lot no I
know but in order for us to establish
everything when it comes to morality how
dressing Etc it all starts here my point
is this you guys believe in things you
don't see but when it comes to God you
say no people study them they Ober the
effects of them when they study them we
can see like for the Consciousness for
example we can be inside the brain and
see how different I'm talking about
conscious I'm not talking about the
brain Consciousness is from the brain no
it's not that's what I'm saying where
would it be from but that's my point
that's what I'm saying is that
Consciousness there's a whole discussion
called the hard problem of Consciousness
it is not there's a whole discussion
about it big scientists are discovering
my argument is the following just
because you cannot see something does
not mean it doesn't exist that's the
what that's the first premise of making
so we can move on me proving God God
proving God is very easy for me the
first thing I'm trying to establish is
this we as human beings believe in
things we don't see but not not all of
us but I mean no no we have to like like
like gravitational force there are many
things that we a human thing you're I I
understand but let's be consistent I'm
saying if we're going to apply that to
other places why is it when it comes to
God no I have to seem to believe but you
don't do with other things because the
whole a choice and then when he says
he's creating everything and have to
follow his religious book we need to see
evidence that he exists your holy book
is not enough for that that's like
saying that's the same argument as
Christians as saying the same thing I'm
not saying that I'm saying let's be
consistent we don't see Consciousness we
believe in it we don't see dark matter
we believe in it so therefore with God
when we don't see it you cannot deny him
now I can prove to you God exists okay
prove it good okay so the first thing we
establish is that if we don't see
something does not mean it doesn't exist
now and I'll prove to you go exist for
example number one uh do you have a
mobile phone yes uh yes can I do M if
you take
out I can take mine okay no problem it's
fine just trying to lond you know we
don't want to get off I'm on YouTube
like here yeah okay I I'll give I'll
give a phone case as an example yeah
this phone case does it have a shape
yeah okay does this have a design yeah
okay does it have a purpose yeah okay
good am I more complex in design or this
case um you okay so did you go did we go
to the factory to see this phone case
made no okay but we do believe that it's
designed and he has a purpose
videoone being in fact that's not the
case with God though okay did you go to
the factory well we could but there's
video evidence before factories we know
how factory production works we have the
have the extensive prior knowledge of
how factories works and how they make
phones we don't have the extensive parge
of how God works and if he even exist If
Video evidence of that we have video
evidence of factories no video evidence
of God and we can go to factory see
don't need to see videos did you guys go
to the factory but we could that's the
thing could could is in the future I'm
talking about now potential I actually
work in a factory okay good so you have
experience in the factory okay and so
that's yes I have okay so are you
telling me that if you did not work in a
factory you will deny that this has a
design so let's suppose you never saw a
factory never worked in a factory you
walk and you said this on the phone go
just came from nothing or would you say
it has a design we would say we would
say I have extensive prior knowledge of
factories and videos of factories and
being t about facts and what they are I
said I said if you did not argum I said
if you did not would you deny this as a
design if you didn't have it okay good
you would use your intuition and your
rational faculties to come to common
factors conclusions which is has a shape
has a design has a purpose as a designer
but then that's the same thing with plan
at us there's other other reasons for
this design like natural selection
Evolution I'm going to the purpose the
purpose and the design could be from
that not good I'm going to come to my
argument why that has to be C my
argument is the following if not having
prior knowledge does not deny this
designed neither you go into the factory
going to the factory means I will go but
right now you believe it a design
without going which means you're using
your rational faculties to come to
conclusions this has a design and I said
are you more complex in design or this
so my argument is the following to be
consistent if we're going to look at
this without going to the factory or
potentially going to the factory and
accept that it has a design you are far
more complex in design so the conclusion
is the following if this is designed you
have to be designed because you're far
more complex well no because we have
video evidence of how the design of that
is made in the first place I I that's a
good example like
God one second guys look I'm saying to
you if you did not go to
the no no look I'm saying okay so I'm
saying that if you had no prior
knowledge or no future knowledge of
going to the factory you've never been
to the factory and you haven't gone to
the factory in this very moment of time
using our rational logical faculties we
will come to a conclusion this has a
design I'm saying as human beings your
eye is far more complex in design than
this mere phone case so if that's the
case your eye has to have a designer but
that Designer is Natural Evolution and
natural selection okay good so now we've
done you've accepted that there's a
designer but you're saying that it's
Natural Evolution yeah okay okay another
example just want to give a supporting
argument why there is design is your DNA
do you know your DNA a single strand of
DNA has more information in it than
every single book on this planet yeah
okay if there's information it requires
intelligence you know you're explaining
God exist why Islam exists no Islam is a
whole different discussion cuz right
here do whole thing about Islam I know
but Islam will come to you later because
he's an atheist he doesn't believe it
for me to go to Islam he's going to say
like he said I don't want to go to your
book he's rightly so he would say you're
going to try to prove to me God exists
with the Quran you don't even believe
the Quran is from God no good that's why
so what I'm trying to do is you're the
is you you believe about he's not so I
want to cater for him so we're on the
same page then we can both go to Islam
so my argument is the following if
there's information information requires
intelligence correct yeah good so the
reason why you look the way you do and
you way you do and the way I do it's DNA
it's information now you said that um
that is evolution evolution is what
evolution is don't take God out the
picture Evolution talks about in a
certain amount of time that if you give
an infin amount of well certain amount
of time there is a chance this can
happen but where did the first cell come
from sorry the first cell first cell
that first cell that replicate itself
Etc where this come cuz the first is a
very complex thing I mean true but it
would have been billions and billions of
years ago but then as said why are you
putting God into Evolution natural
selection in the first place there's no
evidence that he was ever implicated
into like if you're saying that's the
reason designer behind Evolution and
natural selection youd have to prove
that you never did design in the first
place it has to be because the thing is
the first cell is designed it's made up
complex like you said it could have been
chance like it could have been chance
Like For the First Time Chance what does
you mean by chance because Chance is
something that is very random and in
science you don't really have chance
because for example if I flip the coin
and I said heads or tails as a scientist
if I knew all the factors I would know
exactly the results there is no chance
in science because science deals with
what is known if we know all the factors
when throwing a dice the angle you throw
it the temperature the weather all that
kind of stuff we will know the exact
results we only call it chance is
because we we just made this word up
there is no chance in science so to me
when we talk about the universe did the
universe come from nothing or something
I mean it came from something okay what
is that thing because the universe has
all done who created God ask that God
can't no sense okay so so so before we
come to who created God we need to
establish if God exists my point is this
used keep going on about this we want to
know about Islam and why I understand
but he's he's an atheist I need to prove
God to convert him we can talk about
Islam without talking about proing God
no we have to cuz you know why it's me
talking about Islam is is I need to
prove God exists then I can talk about
moral arguments and morality Pro God
exists for us to talk about the rules
and practices of thean is well of course
then I need to show you why Islam is the
truth and not Christianity or not any of
them but I feel like we're just going on
a tangent here which is going be talking
not really because the thing is i' I've
Pro provided evidences which you didn't
deny about the design about the
information the D but then you're
implicating on into that anyway when
there's no evidence for God being
implicated to that in the first place
and if there was a Creator and designer
for
then who the Creator for designer for
God but that's my point because we say
that God is the necessary being if there
was you're just saying that to say it
then how do you know evidence that God
is a necessary being no but that's my
argument so what I'm saying is that I
showed you the design argument from
yourself I use the DNA information
information requires intelligence I
showed you that my form the form case
that we have your far more complex those
are evidences to God existent now you're
asking me who created God it's evidence
for factory production DNA Evolution no
no evolution is a blind process how does
blind process give order well I mean I
get that but still Pro the existence of
okay can zero equal one yeah okay so
there something began the
universe cuz it cannot come from nothing
can something come from nothing but then
what did God come from okay that's but
that's my that's my point cuz that's
just that just keeps
going person cre came from the person
that created that person okay from the
person that created that then we will
never be here that's my point so do you
accept that we have to have a power
source that created everything yeah but
it doesn't have to be God okay what is
it I'm not sure no one really knows no
no no no logically and rationally if
something for example if I show you a
painting by look at a painting there are
certain things that you can know about
the painter number one that the painter
exists you've never seen him number two
his drawing you know he had the will to
paint number three he's good at painting
there's so many attributes that you can
give to that painter by just looking at
the painting so when I look at you and
the way you're created your mouth your
tongue your eyes Etc you cannot come and
tell me Evolution randomly all of a
sudden put your teeth in your mouth so
lucky and your diges that makes more
sense than Allah okay
let okay that makes more sense that a
Evolution a first cell randomly no order
came from nothing poed into existence
gave us order so much that my legs are
in its right place my eyes and and but
but let me tell a second how does that
make more sense you're just assuming
that humans have a purpose on this
planet create people just to worship Him
your argument your argument is your
question why God did something I'm
trying to prove God exists and so far
I've given that you guys haven't rebuked
all you ask me is it doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense okay so God a Creator
exists gives order but the universe only
one why why is that that makes what do
you think about all the other religions
like Christianity that's but that's what
I'm saying I am coming to that the
reason why I'm going to tell you why not
Christianity arum no they don't let me
tell you why because they believe Jesus
Is God we don't believe man is God yes
so that's
why look look I I can make an look I've
shown you a couple of arguments why God
existed yes which is that he cannot come
from nothing Universe cannot come from
nothing impossibility you don't have any
proof you're just saying it has look it
has to be God because there is no other
explation doesn't have to be there can
be another we don't know for sure how do
you know for sure it's God it's because
from nothing nothing comes but you don't
know it's God for sure okay is
there did our universe begin to exist
sorry did our universe begin to exist
yes at some point okay so then that
means a being gave rise to it willed it
maybe not God one second okay if
somebody Wills something they have the
power of will meaning they decided for
the universe to began to exist so that's
an
attribute which you repeat that that's
an attribute the universe began to exist
meaning something or some being will the
universe to begin yes but how do you
proof that's God okay some you said
yourself something to be a being let's
not call it good does this thing have
the power of
will I mean yes okay good is there
information in our universe yeah then
that means if there's information in our
universe that that whatever it is has to
have knowledge I mean I guess depend
iess power in our universe yeah okay
that that means that being or whatever
it is that wi it has knowledge has also
power yeah okay good so that is who we
call Allah but then it couldn't but
that's call that might not be a being it
might be a thing it might have been like
the big bang that might have been what
created the universe no one big bang is
a material thing I'm tell telling you
before it doesn't have to be it doesn't
have to be a being you said yourself it
could be something okay but I said to
you bang is that's something that's
something that has wield it has
knowledge has power is Allah well it
depends on how you define power and
knowledge Big Bang has power but I might
not have the knowledge might have just
created everything Big Bang does not
have power on its own Big Bang started
at one point it creat the entire no it
no it didn't what came before the Big B
my friend it's like me giving you £50
and you than the £50 I gave you it
you're giving credit to the £50 not me
I'm saying the you the big there's a
difference between the £50 in you and
the big band and God no but the
comparison I'm giving is it's like me
giving you £50 and you're £50 thank you
very much I'm like I gave you it you're
giving the credit to the wrong place
reminds me no no I just want to say that
reminds me sorry sorry sorry you know
how you know when something good happens
in your life you thank Allah when
something bad happens in your life you
thank Shan like no not than thank Allah
no no saying when something bad happens
you you um you say it's because ofan no
well I mean CU Allah says in the Quran
the good and the bad is from Allah okay
but anyway let's look that you thank
Allah good happens it's like you take
you take the credit from you cuz you're
the one who did the work Allah did not
help did what work look you're the one
who got no I didn't let me tell you
something let me tell you something look
let me tell you something because I did
not I didn't wake up and say I want my
eyes to be working my heart I didn't
create myself God created me so why
would I give credit to myself into the
process of no because I have because I
have many I have many you're implicating
yourself into all these different poses
that make up evidence that
that saying that's like a Christian
saying oh God was there to make me the
Christian God was there to make me
that's how you saying the Muslim God was
there to make no no not the Muslim God
the reason why I told you a being who
has a will who has power who has
knowledge has to have these attributes
because they are in the universe so he
has to be the all knowing he has to be
the all powerful he has to have a will
he had if he okay how could something
give some rise to something that it
doesn't in have because of adaption
evolution of time what what does that
mean yeah because we M don't know what
that means what you no no well you're
making words that you don't even know
what it means what do you mean about ad
adaptation what does that mean just over
time humans evolving what does that mean
if I had an empty cop here and I said
give it infinite amount of time we would
have a Ferrari the components to make a
Ferrari are not in the cup time is
irrelevant to the equation so what I'm
saying is the following that that thing
we're talking about the reason we call
it Allah and not the Christian God or
any other God is the reason Christians
believe Jesus Is God we say God cannot
be a man so we say that's the reason why
that cannot be God the Hindus come and
say we believe in 1 million Gods the god
of power and the God of this and the god
of that we say no God has to be one
which you ask why is God one but not 10
because if there was more than one God
Allah says in the Quran there would have
been chaos because there would be Gods
fighting each other that's why God has
to be one so my argument let me tell you
why why is less than let me tell you why
this is my final argument which
solidifies why God exists it's argument
from contingency there are three types
of existence there's impossible
existence there is necessary existence
and there's depend uh contingent
existence yeah for example an impossible
existence is a triangle square it
doesn't it cannot exist am I right cuz a
triangle has three sides and A square
has four sides so but you cannot have a
triangle square would you agree yes good
so we're left with two possibilities a
necessary existence and a possible
existence me and you we are contingent
beings we depend on other things for our
survival am I correct yeah okay good so
what we see is the following we cannot
have an infinite regress of dependent
things so I depend on food and food
depends on this and our planet depends
on the gravitational force and the
universe and the Sun and you cannot have
an infinite regress of depend things
that's why I said it all has to stop at
one point which is the necessary being
because he's independent self-sufficient
and he's the one that begins on
otherwise we would never be here if you
said well who created God who created
God we would have a fallacy of infinite
regress which goes on forever and we
will never be here that's the reason why
you need to have a necessary being that
is independent self-sufficient and is
not composed of pieces that's my
argument because otherwise you have an
infinite regret of dependent things
that's just another argument supporting
argument for God exists now if you
accept that then I can move on to
Islam No I think it's a very valid
argument from necessary from design from
information intelligence that God exist
there's no other explanation all right
but you're in BO you believe anyways but
no no I believe in that God exist but he
left he left us I can't why would he
leave us what kind of God is that
purpose what kind of purpose of God is
that he Witnesses all the that's
going
on he created us he can choose to do it
I to claim he's all loving God if he's
like not this is why when I talked about
the being another attribute we give to
God Almighty Allah is he's the all wise
because there are evil things that
happen on Earth I'll give you an example
my my child 3 years old doesn't know
anything about fire there's a fire and I
see her running and I'm like the closest
thing to me is my leg got long legs I'm
going to kick my child and divert them
from the fire to my child do you not
think they are seeing fire as something
they can play with I kicked her does she
think I'm evil
no why not I just kicked her she was
going to play with fire she's going to
she believes in you she's you're you're
the guardian no I kicked her yeah but
they don't understand that's my point is
she not going to say dad kicked me and
start crying they they hurt because of
the pain but they don't understand it
good but are they not going to cry and
say why did God yes they will okay good
yes they will but what was my intent
your intent was to get them out of
danger good so just because they don't
have the wisdom in what I was doing they
saw me as that is evil but that saved
your life the point is
the child's going to move on they're
think Dad is evil like that comparisons
are very like a phone to God a phone
case to God and that's completely
different I mean I mean they work
because you didn't content against it
that's not evil how God I never said I
never said my daughter's going to know
me as evil for the rest of our life that
moment of time she be evil evil try okay
right no problem dad dad dad dad HT me
dad is what you want to don't call evil
what you want to call it okay the point
is yeah the point is move on from it
they're going to move on from it just I
didn't say they're going to remember for
the the rest of their life because when
they grow up I'm they're going to know
why I did it my point is the following
you said there are bad things happening
on Earth that's called the problem of
evil you're saying if God exists why is
he letting it happen and my point is
this we have the pixel he has the
picture just because you don't know why
a certain thing happened doesn't mean
it's bad how many times in life I've
gone through stuff which was terrible
but it was the best thing that ever
happened to me cuz Allah says in the
Quran you might hate something which is
good for you and you might love
something which is bad for you how many
times all the time sense are evil
I'm seeing allow that happen to someone
is that like a test or trial why why
they allow to happen to a child just
been Bor for okay good so what I'm
saying is has has Allah said raping a
child is good no no but why is he
allowing that to happen why would he
test a child like that why create who
think like okay okay good what I'm
saying to you is the following there are
people who go through different
difficulties in life rape murder killing
cancer uh natural disasters Etc yeah and
there are two types of people there are
people who take lessons out the stuff
that they went through and there are
people who rebel against it why did this
happen to me why did that I've seen
people in both spectrums there are those
who said you know what I went through
this specific thing in life it was
traumatic for me it really made me
question but it made me better and more
of a closer relationship with God but
that can happen with a child if a child
gets how does that make them better let
give some
TR things what what I'm saying what I'm
saying is this God hasn't commanded
anyone to rape anybody if a person does
that evil that is the reason why to your
world view as an atheist you have no EXP
explation for a disabled person you have
no explanation for the child that got
raped what Justice can you give that
person by saying sorry guys it's
Evolution not only that our brain are
made from Evolution you're going to say
you know what you can't even blame
anybody because the evolution process
that can be an explanation
how because just over perspective so how
from the atheistic perspective our
brains have evolved I how could you even
trust your brain that you're here how do
you know we're not in the Matrix I mean
there people who believe that but then
we just look around us and we just
observe everything anyway okay good so
what I'm talking about this is why
morality has to come from God answering
your question about Islam when we talk
about morality if we don't have
objective morality we have subjective
morality which means the following you
asked about clothing morality is based
on our empathy and our Humanity anyway
no in what
way like if you see a starving person on
the street you will help them not
everyone well not everyone sure because
everyone's different different
personalities but a basic empathy that
like most people have and some people
might not have it because of the you
know there might be Psychopaths they
might be they just might be not morally
inclined because of whatever is going on
in their life but when did they get the
from like for example today we're living
in at a time where they want to make
incest legal do you believe incest is is
moral no okay why because the harm can
do to the Future chart and the fact that
what harm if they use protection defects
at BIR protection protection a brother a
brother and sister having intimacy they
use protection how is that protection is
not it's not going to protect make you
now get what they're not going to have
children no you it's just the fact that
you're related that it would just be
just be wrong because it's two people
who have similar DNA but they love each
other
I wouldn't really classify as love why
not because now see see what's happened
now subjectively like would you forgive
me it's personal sexual orientation are
you straight uh yeah okay so now my my
argument is the following there are
people who are gay and they say I love
men okay so we say then why do you not
support incest rights for a brother and
sister to marry each other compare
people that love it to adults consenting
adults to I think it's more
disrespectful for the community that if
men love each
other illegal who decided to Beal oh
sorry
legal what is what is homosexualy
actually for harm what does it harm of
course for example straight
people people harm a lot those who have
sex outside of marriage correct that's
why we believe the nuclear family is
what we're talking about here but people
have the nuclear family without
believing in a religion they can be
atheist not necessarily because the
reason why today what we have we have t
of people who have nuclear families who
are a no no of course this what I'm
saying you need object morality to have
you morals otherwise you have sub
morality see morality differently that's
the thing a basine morality can come
from cultural background um who you are
as a person it can even be in some ways
biological like mirror neurons like that
kind of stuff there is no evidence
biologically about someone being that
but what I'm saying is a following you
are talking about subjective things I
told you about inset you said no how
could it be but a person there are
people in courts in Europe they are
trying to fight for inest rights so
they're saying how come your love is
love when you marry a man and a man or a
woman and a woman but my love to my
daughter or my love to my sister or my
brother you're denying my love do you
see my point because because a dad and
dad and daughter he's he watched the
child grow up that's that's that's
demented okay you you can
say why DED that a brother and sister
love each other and they would have
intimacy they grew up like they grew up
with each other that's what made them
love each other more but they they but
do you see where are you coming from
comes up with standards by itself anyway
that's the problem when Society com ARG
religion to do that yes you do let me
tell you why for example Allah says in
the Quran he tells us the people who can
marry and the people who cannot marry in
today's time when you don't have a
guideline and a way of life that's why I
was saying I have a way of life you have
a way of life you have a way of life you
don't need God for that way of life you
do because if you don't this is the
reason why today they're trying toiz
incest why do atheist live and and by
the way pedopilia as well Inc is like a
big thing in Muslim countries by the way
sorry what is that in is big thing in
Muslim countries how okay what do you
mean by Inc incest no what's incest
what's your definition of incest is is
marrying someone that you're related to
is dating someone you're related to who
defined that for example you're marrying
your first cousin how question okay good
but that's my issue but that's my issue
when you say Society decides it Society
is decided from a subjective source
which is the brain which they do not
know this is why I say to you God is all
KN brain then no God no that's my
argument the subjective people who don't
believe in God where do they get their
morality from they they they observe
they think oh this is good but we know
the harms for example pornography
pornography is legal correct yeah it is
one of the biggest disasters on human
history when what it does to human
beings okay there are people like T
Bundy who's going into a massive Killing
Spree because he saw a pornographic
magazine when he was young and God is
watching that and not getting involved
God any second no no no no no that's the
point that's why I said that being has
to be the all wise because there are
things that we don't understand and just
because we don't understand doesn't mean
it's wrong because there's a day of
judgment for your world view a child
that was raped how could you give them
Justice in this life person that rap
them okay and how's that going to bring
them back anything and being counseling
and trying to we
good good but the point this how is not
going to help them C or anything like
that something like that might not
happen if you punish someone right now
is they can see it is is definite pun
but like telling them there might be
help might be on the day of judgment
good but good that's my point so we're
saying from our world view there is
Justice in the Hereafter there this
world if you look at this world just by
our life that we live here nothing will
make sense that's why God makes sense to
everything morality all the stuff you
otherwise you have subjective people
like for example they're trying to
legalize
pedopilia and what's what do you define
as a legal age in the UK is 16 in France
they made it 15 you go to America is 14
12 so where
it's no no no no in Turkey certain
countries but in certain states with
parents who consider get married at 12
there was 250,000 I agree with that but
then we have studies on on the brain and
the psychology to understand when
someone can't get that kind of stuff but
see what I'm saying is the following
when we don't have God we are all over
the place cuz we're trying to find Tru
always in London right now in right now
which
is look at London right
now is London all over the
place is is London all over the place
the reason why people who don't and do
believe in God but the people who don't
believe in God aren always all over the
place and even be the people it can even
be the people what about what about
about Islamic countries where they are
all over the place and that people
facing persecution for being gay for
having adultery
count see us right so what about the
people are suffing in those and going
being all over the place in those
countries so the reason is because Islam
deals with protecting the communal
rights as a whole so for example do you
believe drinking alcohol casually is
okay yeah why because because in this
country culture and what people want to
do we just believe that if alcohol in in
a limited in like a tiny like you know
restrained amount not like you're
becoming an alcoholic you know
restrained amount you know that's okay
good so what you've done is by Society
standards and peer pressure and other
cultural things you've decided that
someone just having a little glass here
also we can just see the effects of
alcohol on the brain on the liver so we
know that in certain quantities it can
be okay but in a large amount it can
just be bad recent studies recent
studies show opposite the recent studies
show that any form of alcohol is not
good for you recent studies you can
check it why because let me ask you a
question somebody drinks and then they
swerve and hit four people which happens
a lot I was watching a docent a couple
of days ago drink driver no one's one
second that moderation that moderation
that guy started I'm sure he didn't wake
up one day and said I'm going to have
four vodkas he started with a glass and
that glass led to another glass and
another glass that he drunk that's
that's what Al that's Al got drinking
more is though like eating a lot of
drunk
food phas that's my point my point is
this what Islam does is the following
prevention is better than cure instead
of saying hey look guys no Islam says no
no no no no my friend one person no but
this is what I'm saying you're behind a
casino do you know how many lives get
destroyed by a casino do you know how
many men commit suicide because they
spend their wealth on they go here a
woman the whole point is the Lord gives
them that will to free will to do that
but that's the point the point is this
is why Islam you this is why Islam I
believe is a Tru all religions yeah
because God tells you what is good for
you before you test trial and kill
yourself but even then there's certain
things in religions that you might
believe aren't good for you anyway let's
talk about what is good for you casino
going and gambling a man who has kids at
home goes and takes his life savings and
wastes it in under 10 minutes is that
good or bad okay yes it can be bad but
someone repressing on the flip side with
Islam someone repressing their sexuality
their orientation that can be bad for
them too there's loads of mental health
consequences do that we we will come to
that my argument is let's deal with what
God says drinking alcohol is it good or
bad it's the biggest poison on earth
that is legal you know how many people
go to NHS liver cancer breast cancer
which is caused by that by the way I
it's really funny cuz they do a much for
breast cancer and they go and drink the
C with wine which causes the breast
cancer yeah it doesn't cause you just to
have a glass of wine and making an
argument that have junk food too much of
it do the same thing sorry want go to
Chinese :6 do you mind if we go off to
do you want to go to the queen place now
yeah okay do you mind if we we're going
to go to the queen p yeah that's fine
all right well thank you
bye yeah so anyways there you can see
guys um we're trying to make uh some
nice discussions about yeah look you
know this is this issue you know when
we're trying to make Arguments for Why
God exists Etc I mean you can't really
force people if somebody doesn't want to
believe they don't want to believe you
know and I was there having a discussion
a dialogue trying to prove to them but
it's just like one after another bang
bang bang and then before I can answer
it we're going to go why because it
makes sense it makes logical explanation
it makes sense so anyways I ask Allah to
guide them uh inshah the prophet
sallallahu alhi wasallam said whoever
builds a Masid for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala Allah will build for him
a similar house in jenah on that day
where Allah subhana tala tells us that
our books will be given and every little
atom weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masid I never had the money to
build a Masid Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
[Music]